Musik Da sind wir wieder. Da sind wir. Da sind wir. Da sind wir dabei, war ist prima. Nein, wir sind voll Glora, da habe ich überhaupt keine Lust drauf. Sag mal, Stefan, was ich nochmal fragen wollte, wie geht es eigentlich ... Ja, jetzt muss was kommen von dir. Jetzt muss ein Gag kommen von dir eigentlich, aber in der Frage hätte schon ein Gag kommen sollen. Kamen nicht. Kamen. Ist es eine Anzeige dafür, wie die Folge sich im weiteren Verlauf abbilden wird? Ich bin mir nicht sicher. Lass uns mal ganz kurz zusammenfassen. Gestern saßen wir in genau diesem Studio, hatten die Mikrofone aufgebaut, haben Sachen aufgenommen, haben uns aber dafür entschieden, nicht die Podcast-Folge aufzunehmen, weil ich zitiere … Sondern Geld verlangen zu wollen. Genau, wir haben dann lieber den Patreon-Account eingerichtet, anstatt die Folge aufzunehmen, weil ich zitiere, Stefan müde war. Oh, der war müde, aber müde dann hier nochmal den Patreon-Account aufzumachen. Wach genug, um sehr viel Geld zu verlangen. Nochmal schön den Zuschauer an den Knöchel zu packen und schön das Geld rauszuschütteln, schön den Sack aufzumachen und die Talerein fallen zu lassen.
Also auch einer, ein User hat geschrieben, wir wollen heute ein bisschen auf die User eingehen,
einer hat geschrieben, nicht erscheinen, aber Geld verlangen. Und irgendwie ist es genau unser
Ding. So, weil wir sind ein Podcast, wir haben schon unsere Mikrofone, wir haben alles schon,
was wir zum Aufnehmen brauchen, Leute haben unsere Quantqualität des Öfteren gelobt,
wir haben also alles, was wir brauchen, schon in sehr guter Ausführung und verlangen trotzdem noch Geld, obwohl wir damit nichts machen können. Interessante Dynamik. Du hast den Post geliked, ich habe ihn wieder entliked. Welchen Post denn? Den du gerade erwähnt hast, den Tweet. Nur damit ihr mal da draußen wisst, wie ungefähr das Podcast auf dem Social Media Team funktioniert. Einer liked und dann sind uns oft nicht ganz einig, wie wir die Community umzugehen haben, weil Community ist ein hartes Thema und das ist heute auch das Thema, über das wir mal sprechen wollen. Community. Ihr habt zu viel Geld. Geld macht nicht glücklich. Und da wollen wir heute mal ein bisschen drüber reden. Geld macht lustig, ist uns aufgefallen. Ja. Und da wollen wir dann ansetzen, glaube ich, um euch da, ich glaube, Geld ausgeht macht glücklich. Zu dem Thema haben haben wir direkt am Telefon den Glücksforscher Professor Doktor Dietsch von der Universität Tübingen. Guten Tag. Schönen guten Namen, hallo. Sie forschen ja an Glück. Das ist ja für viele ein recht subjektiver Begriff. Kann man denn überhaupt Glück erforschen oder muss das jeder für sich selbst tun? Glück kann man nicht erforschen, haben zumindest die Leute gesagt, denen ich gesagt habe, dass ich Glücksforscher bin. Ich hätte dann einfach diesen Namen eintragen lassen und bislang hat es noch niemand in Frage gestellt. Sie sind der Erste, der mich anruft. Ich bin seit Jahren arbeitslos und habe mich jetzt als Glücksforscher ausgegeben. Ja. Und sie rufen mich jetzt an. Na gut. Haben Sie denn das Glück gefunden, nachdem Sie jetzt schon so lange suchen? Ich bin, muss ich sagen, ziemlich glücklich. Ich meine, ich bin beruflich jetzt gar nichts, wie gesagt, und ich bin sehr zufrieden.
Ich meine, jeden Tag laufen gute Sachen im Fernsehen.
Eine Frage, die uns immer wieder erreicht ist, macht Geld glücklich?
Ja.
Vielen Dank, Herr Doktor Dietsch von der Universität Tübingen. Glück auf oder was sagt man da?
Petri Heil.
Petri Heil wegen Frauke...
Oh, da muss aber eine Menge Jäger, glaube ich. Oder wer sagt Petri Heil? Wolfgang Petri. Wolfgang Jäger. Sagt Petri Heil. Ja. Die müssen sich so etwas Neues überlegen, ne? Nein. Wieso? Verstehe ich nicht. Naja, jetzt wegen Frauke Petri. Mit wem reden Sie jetzt gerade? Wie redest du jetzt noch mit mir, Herrn Jäger vom Dachschutzverband Glück, oder mit wem redest du jetzt gerade? Ich rede mit Frauke Petri gerade. Schön, dass ich Sie heute hier begrüssen darf. Danke, dass ich da war. Haben Sie Angst, dass Petri Heil das neue Heil Hitler wird? Ja. Gedenken Sie, einen neuen Gruss, einen neuen deutschen Gruss einzuführen, bevor die Bevölkerung von sich aus anfängt, Petri Heil als neues Heil Hitler zu verwenden. Ich will ja gar nicht in diese rechte Ecke geschoben werden. Deswegen habe ich damit eigentlich keinen … Lassen Sie mich über den Euro sprechen. Wie würden Sie denn gerne gegrüsst werden auf der Strasse? Sowas wie, ähm, hei, fände ich gut. Hei, Frauke … Hei, hei, hei, Frauke? Heil, Heil, Frauke. Heil, Frauke, ja. Habe Sie mich jetzt falsch verstanden. Macht Geld glücklich? Nein. Vielen Dank, Frauke Petri von der Universität Tübingen. Wir kommen zurück zu Doktor Wolfgang Jäger von der Universität Bremen. Das war ein Hörspiel, ein Hörspiel, ein wunderbares Hörspiel, ein kleines Hörspiel, ein kleines, gellies Hörspiel, ein kleines Hörspiel. Und wir haben euch betrogen, denn wir haben gesagt, bei 50 Euro machen wir weniger Hörspiele. Aber wir haben noch schon viel mehr als 50 Euro. Na, aber wir haben das neue Goal noch nicht erreicht. Du hast Patreon nicht verstanden. Aber ich weiß, sieht man da auch die Ziele nicht. Du ziehst den Leuten das Geld aus der Tasche, ohne zu verstehen, warum. Ja, aber da sieht man die Ziele dann nicht, weil ich weiss aber nicht, was das nächste Ziel ist. Ich habe selber völlig die Orientierung verloren. Hundert Euro war unser Ziel … mehr Hörspiele … mehr lustiger, alles in allem lustiger zu sein. Ja, zum Glück ist das noch nicht erreicht. Und wir wollen dich zwangsläufig klonen. Ja, ich weiss. Und dann wollen wir jede Woche live einen Florentin töten. Man weiss nie genau, welchen Florentin trifft es. So wie South Park. Den vom Anfang ist es dann der Klon und in Folge 80 hat man völlig den Verstand verloren. So wie South Park meinst du, so mit Catphrase? Ja, oder wie in dem Film Prestige. Puh, das hat mir noch eingefallen, Gott sei Dank, wow! Gerade noch, gerade noch wie einer der Lemminge, der immer so die Treppe vor sich baut und über den nächsten Stein vor sich. Ich bin so lange gezögert, dass man gar nicht mit einem guten Vergleich gerechnet,
dann kommt noch Prestige um die Ecke und denkt, okay, das hat tatsächlich nur Sinn gemacht.
Das war ganz geil.
So, kommen wir zum nächsten Thema.
Die Zuschauer haben uns Fragen gestellt für heute.
Wir wollen nämlich mal ein bisschen auf die Community eingeben, denn jetzt, wo ihr zahlt, habt ihr gewisse Rechte.
Da wollen wir ein bisschen darauf eingehen.
Stefan hat sich da mal ein bisschen was zusammengeschrieben.
Was dürfen denn die Hörer jetzt, wo sie für den Podcast zahlen müssen? Das fände ich echt lustig. Also wenn wir jemals dafür von den Zuschauern verlangen, dass sie zahlen müssen, dann will ich nicht mehr leben eigentlich. Ich kann mir ja schon vorstellen, dass die Community diesen Schnipsel aufbewahren wird, um in zwei Jahren, wenn wir das Podcast Money Ufo starten werden und mit bezahlbaren Abosystemen gearbeitet wird, man dir das wieder um die Ohren wirft. Ja, ich glaube auch. Das ist wie mit dem Stylus, wo Steve Jobs mal gesagt hat, bei uns wird sowas niemals geben und jetzt kommen die mit dem Stift um die Ecke und sagen alle, da ist der Stylus. Oder als ich in Folge 1 gesagt habe, ich würde gerne mal einen Oscar gewinnen und als als ich vor zwei Jahren einen Oscar gewonnen habe, hat die Academy so nett und hat den Ausschnitt eingespielt, was, finde ich, ein ganz netter Zug war eigentlich an der Stelle. Unsere Leute, unsere Community, unsere Herzensmenschen, die uns seit Jahrzehnten bei diesem Projekt begleiten, durch Dick und Dünn gehen, nicht zu Gästeliste Geisterbahn oder, Antenne Alderan, Last September in Monaco, wir sind dummen Affen von Last September in Monaco. Ich hasse Last September in Monaco. Und wir haben uns jetzt tolle Fragen gestellt. Zum ersten Mal haben wir eine FAQ Frage gestellt. Ich dachte, da kann man noch einen Gag machen, so statt Frequently Asked, so least frequently asked, so rarely asked. Gut, Dankeschön dafür. So r-a-q. Ich fang mal oben an. Zunächst eine random Frage. Lasst mich durch, ich bin isotonisch. Nicht wirklich eine Frage, von daher kommen wir zum nächsten. Wo ist Booster? Ja, das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Wir haben tatsächlich schon viele Folgen keinen Booster mehr gegessen und ich habe jetzt heute mal den Classic Energy Drink von Freeway Up.
Das ist die Lidl-Hausmarke.
Mit Freeway verbindest du, glaube ich, gute Erinnerungen.
Damals am Lagerfeuer, mit der ganzen Klasse, Geburtstagsfeier,
du hast Chantal eingeladen, du hast Rebecca eingeladen, du hast Vanessa eingeladen.
Niemand ist gekommen, leider, und du sitzt mit deinem Vater am Lagerfeuer
und ihr beide trinkt einfach die Freeway Swirl, glaube ich, hieß die von Aldi.
Ohne Zucker aber. Swirl, genau, die 1,5 Liter Flasche ohne Zucker. Nur Zucker. 1,5 Liter. Oder ihr mischt selbst noch Zucker rein. Wow. Hat jemand mal in Cola noch mehr Zucker reingekommen? Ich glaube, in Cola Light eigentlich, um den Kaloriengehalt wieder herzustellen. Ich finde das sehr lustig, zu versuchen, ob man in Cola noch ein bisschen mehr Zucker reinmachen kann oder ob einfach die Sättigung schon erreicht ist und das einfach oben drauf liegen bleibt. Ich glaube, es würde unten liegen bleiben als Sediment, Sedimentierung nennt man das und das ist sowas ähnliches wie Nukleation. Dummes Arschloch. Ganz kurz mal eben, ohne Scheiss, ich habe keine Lust mehr darauf, dass du mich da immer korrigierst in so einem Scheiss, so einem Nebensatz auch einfach. Ja, warum, aber du, das war jetzt offensichtlich die Fallschule, du sagst, Zucker schwimmt unter Urfläche. Ja, aber das müssen die doch noch, du bringst die doch auch noch drauf, die Leute, die merken das doch sonst nicht. Ja, aber es geht darum, dass wir dem Zuschauer was beibringen, dass wir so ein bisschen ehrlichen Austausch hier haben. Neulich habe ich gesagt mal einmal, dass der Mond sich um die Erde dreht und da hast du gefragt, dreht er sich denn um sich selber? Ich habe gesagt, nein, er dreht sich einmal um sich selber, während er sich um die Erde dreht. Habe ich so nicht gesagt. Ich habe gesagt, er dreht sich nicht, er zeigt der Erde immer die gleiche Seite und habe den Leuten nicht zugemutet, dass ich den gebundenen Rotationen erklären kann. Habe deswegen gesagt, er dreht sich nicht, weil wir immer die gleiche Seite sehen und da hat hat jemand gesagt, tatsächlich, das wäre falsch. Und dann hat man so Facepalm-Smiles. Neben Stefan liegt gerade ein aufgeschlagener Duden auf der Seite der gebundenen Rotation. Gut gemacht. Wir haben so ein Facepalme-Smiley gemacht halt und haben mich offensichtlich als Trottel dargestellt in aller Öffentlichkeit. Und deswegen wollte ich jetzt mal sagen, ich habe euch nicht so getraut. Ja, aber es ist eine interessante Frage. Wie viel trauen wir den Leuten zu? Ja, aber was heisst denn Rotation? Rotation im Vergleich zu was? Das wäre eine dumme Frage. Was heisst Mond? Definiere Mond. Definiere definieren. Definieren bedeutet etwas genauer zu erklären. Oh, meine Herren, du, das war lau. Wie du es jede Folge nicht geschissen kriegst, deinen Kacktöne auszumachen. In dem Moment bimmelt sein Handy auch noch. Bimmelt? Bimmelt, brummelt. Das ist also geil, weil Stefan, manchmal bricht irgendwie so ein anderes Wesen raus, so das Unterbewusstsein, aber anstatt irgendwelchen sexuellen Versprechern oder so, kommen bei ihm so ganz uncoole Worten wie bimmelt statt klingelt manchmal durch. Dein Unterbewusstsein, ich glaube Freud, könnte bei dir einfach analysieren und am Ende kämen keine sexuellen Traumata raus, sondern einfach der uncoolste Mensch, der langweiligste Mensch der Welt, den du verzweifelt versuchst, in dein Unterbewusstsein zu verbannen, der aber rausbricht einfach durch sowas wie bimmelt. Ich habe mir so eine Maske gebaut, was heißt gebaut, ich habe, glaube ich, ich habe so sporadisch so eine Maske drüber gemalt, mit Strassenkreide meinem normalen Ich. Und das versucht immer so rauszubrechen. Aber beim nächsten Regenschauer ist die Fassade einfach wieder weg. Und da steht so ein uncooler Typ, der über die Gänge schlurft und bummelt und bimmelt sagt. Aber nur die beiden Worte. Sehr häufig, zu häufig sagt. Da war eine Frage, wie oft kannst du das Wort tatsächlich in einem Podcast sagen? Meine Antwort wäre gewesen, so oft, dass es Leuten auffällt, die es nicht nur einmal sagen, sondern zehnmal sagen, so oft, dass es den Moderatoren schon unangenehm auffällt. Und zwar so sehr, dass es aber auch nicht mehr lustig ist, wie oft es genannt wird. Ich fand, der Peak war erreicht, als Leute darüber ein Trinkspiel gemacht haben, fand ich ganz ulkig, habe ich einen Moment drüber gelacht. Aber jetzt alles, was darüber hinaus läuft, Leute, man muss auch mal wissen, ich finde auch beim Neomagazin fällt einem oft auch, dass so Insider-Jokes manchmal einfach unlustig sind. Immer der dünne, blasse Junge, so Jan Böhmermann zu sagen, ist irgendwann einfach nicht mehr cool. Aber ich glaube, die Insider per Definition finden es immer die Zuschauer länger lustig als die, die es machen. Ich glaube, das ist immer so. Ich glaube, noch nie fand es jemand länger lustig, der es selber gemacht hat, als die, die es rezipiert haben. Es ist auch die Frage, finden Leute die Sendung lustiger, als die, die es machen? So ein bisschen, also nehmen die generell alles stärker wahr, als es intern wahrgenommen wird. Ich glaube schon manchmal. Bin ich mir nicht sicher? Doch, Ich glaube schon manchmal, weil die tatsächlich auch teilweise
Dinge einfach zufällig lustig finden.
Also ich merke das manchmal, dass Leute
Sachen sagen und die von anderen
Leuten als lustig
gesehen werden, die die gar nicht lustig gemeint haben.
Stimmt, das hatte ich bei meinem Theaterstück. Da habe ich die Hauptrolle
gespielt und einen Penis rausgeholt. Ich habe wie gesagt schon mal
manchmal nicht die
Story habe ich schon nicht verstanden als Hauptfigur.
Und dann habe ich manchmal einfach was gesagt und Leute haben gelacht.
Die haben es aber gar nie als Witz interpretiert.
Und Leute haben einfach dann gelassen da, haben sich weggeschrien, die haben sich also wirklich eingenässt vor Lachen.
Und da hast du gewusst, eines Tages werde ich einen Podcast haben und damit 12 Euro im Monat verdienen.
Nee, eines Tages werde ich was mit Comedy machen, um zu verstehen, warum das gerade lustig war. Um zu analysieren, warum das nicht lustig war. Oder lustig war. Er ist ein Schuss, der? Damals. Lass mal den Satz beenden, mit den Worten des anderen. Ich finde es so geil, wenn du immer versuchst, während du redest, verbal oder mit den Augen Botschaften zu vermitteln. Nicht darauf antworten, nicht darauf antworten, das ist eine Funfrage. Wenn du eine Anekdote erzählst, wild gewaltig, violently wollte ich jetzt sagen. Violently? Ja, he shook his head violently. Wir gucken, glaube ich, zu viele englische Sachen, dass manchmal einfach die deutschen Wörter einfach ausgehen. Neue Frage. Lass uns mal anfangen. Wie fingen die Jahre vor Christi Geburt mit dem Dezember an und endeten mit dem Januar? Mega gute Frage. Ja, hast du mal gehört bestimmt, weil du jeden Tag auf 9-Gag abhängst, mit deinem Vater damals bei 9-Gag gekämpft hast. Lass uns mal das gesellschaftliche Phänomen 9-Gag analysieren. Bei Nine-Gag, findest du Nine-Gag lustig oder findest du es eher peinlich so ein bisschen? Ich habe es jahrelang gemieden, weil ich dieses Memeaufkommen extrem unangenehm fand. Und so immer dieses Bitch-Please und so, da fing das ja an. Das hat mir nicht gefallen. Ja. Da konnte ich nicht drüber lachen. Aber irgendwann dann habe ich so ein paar lustige Sachen entdeckt und habe es für mich entdeckt, dafür, dass man mal nebenbei einfach das so laufen lässt. Das ist genau das Richtige. Nygic ist das perfekte Medium, einfach nebenbei zu scrollen, einfach während man eigentlich arbeiten sollte. Aber ich finde, den normalen Nygic-User stelle ich mir schon sehr unangenehm vor. Sehr unangenehm. Ich finde vor allem, sehr interessant ist immer das gesellschaftliche Phänomen der unpopular opinion. Es gibt ja dieses Meme mit diesem, ich keine Ahnung, was das für eine Art von Vogel ist, der da so fortschreitet, der da so nachdenkend rumschreitet, und das ist das Unpopular Opinion Meme. Und das ist ja an sich schon Widerspruch in sich, dass man nur die Unpopular Opinion Memes sieht, die auf die Topseite gewotet werden, also die am beliebtesten sind, also die beliebtesten, unbeliebten Meinungen. Was ja schon interessant ist, weil da kommt dann sowas wie keine Ahnung, bin ich der Einzige hier, der nicht will, dass Trump Präsident wird und das hat dann mega viele Votes und du denkst dir einfach, das ist einfach im Internet, in der Ecke, in dem es Internet ist, in der man sich bewegt, einfach komplette Allgemeinmeinungen. Aber die Leute wollen trotzdem, dass es als unpopular opinion gesehen wird. Sie liken das trotzdem, weil sie sagen, stimmt, ich bin auf deiner Seite, wir sind genauso diese eingeschworene Gruppe, die denkt, wir sind in der Unterzahl und die das machen. Das finde ich interessant. Ist glaube ich nicht schlecht, wenn du beliebt sein willst, oft dir Minderheitsmeinungen suchst, die aber eigentlich keine sind. Also oft dir Dinge suchst, die klingen, als wäre das total seltsam und so. Ja, genau. Dann lachen auch, glaube ich, Leute oft. Also wenn zum Beispiel Louis C.K. sagt, wow, jeder freut sich, wenn er furzt und es stinkt total doll und Gandhi auch oder so, weiss ich nicht, habe ich es im Mund gelegt. Ich habe gerade einen Joke für Louis C. C. geschrieben nebenbei. Wow, ich bin so gut, ich bin einfach ein Genie. Und dann sagt man halt, dann sagen Leute, okay, die lachen dann, weil sie sich selber nicht getraut haben, das niemals so zu formulieren oder zu erzählen oder artikulieren, und dann lachen die darüber, weil sie so aus, ja, genau so geht es mir auch, das ist dieses Observational Comedy von wegen der Lachbarn ja, weil es einem auch schon mal aufgefallen ist. Observational Comedy würde ja nicht funktionieren, wenn es nicht zumindest mal beobachtet werden konnte. Und das ist, glaube ich, genau das Phänomen. Aber ich glaube, wenn man so neige als Person wäre, er ein sehr netter Mensch trotzdem. Nee, ich glaube, ein sehr unangenehmer Mensch. Es gibt ja auch dieses Bon mot, dieses kleine Schmankerl, dieses Vokabular-Gustus-Stückerl, ein Schmankerl. Nein, das ist was, was du vorgesagt hast. Ein Bonmot. Bonmot, kennst du so geflügeltes Wort? Nee. Schade. Bonmot geschrieben. Bonmot, genau. Das kenne ich. Geschrieben. Die Mehrheit der Leute denkt, sie sei die Minderheit. So, und ich glaube, das ist ganz interessant.
Du hast ein Fachwort dafür, worüber, nee, das war nicht Bonmot. Nein, Bonmot ist sowas wie Geflötes, damit beschreibt man nicht nur diesen Satz, Stefan, das wäre ein bisschen übertrieben. Und das finde ich interessant bei dem Meme, dass man da genau zeigt, dass die Mehrheit möchte, dass es die Meinung der Minderheit ist. Obwohl sie mal eine Folge Ernst ist. Wollen wir mal eine Folge im Stehen aufnehmen, weil du hast mir diesen dummen Schemel hergegeben. Du hättest dir genau so einen Stuhl holen können. Es gab keinen mehr draußen. Glaubst du, erwartest du, dass ich jetzt dir einen Stuhl hole oder was? Es gab keinen mehr draußen, selbst du kennst mir keinen holen draußen. Du kannst auf Cajon sitzen, das ist doch viel cooler als auf so einem langweiligen Stuhl. Ich kann auf unserem Spanischen Aussage-Praktikanten sitzen. Ja, spielen wir was!
Und Sie hören Stefan Titzel mit seiner neuen Depretation von Gustav Clemens' Die See-Rose.
Bitteschön. Ganz kurz, ist es hier das Seminar für Buchhaltung? Nee, Sie sind im Cajon für fortgeschrittene Seminar, Alternative Cajon-Kunst im 20. bis 29. Jahrhundert. Ach so. Unter Karl dem Grossen. Ja. Ich wollte eigentlich woanders hin, ich wollte eigentlich in den Finanzkurs, weil ich habe Schulden. Nein, die sind hier im Cajon-Kurs für Fortgeschrittene unter der parlamentarischen Monarchie von 98, der versucht … Ja, ich weiß, aber eigentlich wollte ich woanders hin, weil ich habe sehr viel Schulden und ich wollte mir so ein Finanzseminar anhören. Ja, aber hier sind sie im Cajon-Kurs für Fortgeschrittene unter der Herrschaft von Ludwig dem 23.19. Ich weiß, ich weiß. Während sie hier einfach erst reinlaufen. Ja, aber wie gesagt, ich habe sehr viel Schulden und solange sie in der Tür stehen, kommen wir hier so auch nicht weiter. Wollen Sie sich einfach hier mitmachen? Das ist der Cajon-Kurs für Fortgeschrittene im 12. Jahrhundert. Für Fortgeschrittene. Für wem? Nach wem? Sind Sie fortgeschritten? Ich würde gerne fortschreiten durch die Tür. Ach komm Leute, da war es nicht so schlecht, oder? Niemand lacht hier in dem Kurs. Sie sind alleine in dem Kurs. Sie sind alles kracholig. Nur weil Sie ein paar… Wie lange sitzt Sie schon alleine hier? Die waren doch eben noch da, als Sie reingekommen sind, waren Sie noch da. Sie haben ein paar T-Shirts mit anderer Kleidung ausgestopft und ins Publikum gesetzt. Hier ist niemand. Sie sind alleine hier. Aber die Bastelbeile sind torschen ja echt aus. Wie Gesichter. Nicht wirklich, ehrlich gesagt. Zumal die Gesichter sind auf der anderen Seite. Ich muss Ihnen sagen, ich kann gar keinen Cajon spielen. Ich weiss ehrlich gesagt nicht mehr, was ein Cajon ist, deswegen ... Ein Hörspiel! Ein Hörspiel.
Die Leute werden so viel Geld spenden, nur um diese Scheisshörspiele endlich zu beenden. Das ist ein Graus, das ist ein Grauen, ein Gräuel. Ich war ja... Ganz kurz. Ja, ganz kurz. Ja, okay. Aber ganz kurz eine Sache. Alles klar. Ich war beim Netto und kennst du die Situation, wenn du dich an eine Schlange anstellen willst und du stellst dich an die Schlange ganz hinten an und die Person vor dir geht noch kurz was holen, hat noch was vergessen und holt was. Knallhart dazwischen stellen, keinen Platz vorhalten, nicht wie nicht vorlassen. Naja, angenommen die Person hat offensichtlich was vergessen, geht weg und ist nach zwölf Sekunden wieder da. Und du hast aufgeschlossen, lässt du die Person vor oder nicht? Ich lasse alle in dem Laden vor, aber die Person nicht. Weil man hat daran zu denken an die Dinge. Der Supermarkt ist immer gleich aufgebaut. Aber wenn sie jetzt wirklich nur zwei, drei Schritte weg geht zu dem nächsten Regal. Ach, du meinst so ein... Na, ich versuche auszufinden, wo die Grenze ist. Gute Frage. Ab welchem Punkt man nicht mehr ... Ich überlege auch manchmal, wenn Leute hinter mir stehen und nur eine Flasche isotonischen Drink haben oder so, ob ich die vorlassen würde. Ich glaube nämlich nicht. Weil ... Deswegen freue ich mich immer so, dass Leute mich vorlassen. Die haben genug Energie. Und die brauchen Energie. Die brauchen Energie. Ja. Wie wenig darf man haben, um vorgelassen werden zu müssen? Zu müssen.
Wenn die einen leeren Einkaufswagen haben und sie gar nichts haben?
Ist es dir unangenehm, mit dem gar nichts aus dem Supermarkt zu kommen?
Ist es tatsächlich.
Vor allem, ich muss auch immer was kaufen.
Ich kaufe immer die prepaid Handyaufladung.
Wird das noch lustig?
Nee.
Okay, du wolltest auch was anderes anfangen? Aber sehr vorausschauend von dir, dass du gefragt hast. Das ist der neue Stefan. So mit so einem Sendeplan im Hintergrund. Wird das noch lustig? Okay, alles klar, wir brechen sofort. Wir haben ja keine Zeit für untersehende Storys. Wir brechen die Story ab. Ich wollte kurz über Ostern sprechen. Oder du erzählst einfach eine andere Story.
Ja, ist klar. Nee, das ist mir gerade wichtig, weil ich finde nämlich folgendes, wir haben noch nie richtig mal über Ostern gesprochen.
Ich würde jetzt mal gerne das Filetiermesser anlegen und so das Filetstück des Humors aus Ostern rausschneiden.
Okay, was ist doch.
Weil ich finde, das haben wir noch nicht gemacht.
Aber glaubst du, wir kriegen es hin, ohne die Verbindung zwischen Eiern und Hoden zu ziehen?
Auf jeden Fall. Das wäre für mich ein Game Over, wenn wir das müssten. Was denn die Eier? Ja, wir machen das mal. Ich habe tatsächlich auch über Ostern jeden geblockt auf Twitter, der diesen Gag in irgendeiner Hinsicht gemacht hat. Oh Gott, das ist wirklich entdeckt. Ja, ich würde gerne darüber sprechen. Also, was ist da schiefgelaufen eigentlich bei der Planung dieses Festes? Ich verstehe den Ursprung, man will die Auferstehung Jesu feiern. Der Bruder von Jesus. Der dumme Bruder, Besus. Besus Bistus. Besu. Ja? Ja, ja. Ne, man wollte das immer mal feiern, aber dann hat man gesagt, okay, wie? Und dann hatte man ja schon diesen Mann, der anderen Geschenke bringt und so. Wer hat Ideen. Der war ja schon dann besetzt. Und dann, ich finde es nämlich ein bisschen random alles. Also wir haben schon Kürbisse mit Gesichtern drin. Wir haben schon einen Mann und einen Baum. Wir haben schon, die Idee, da bin ich jetzt auch nicht hundertprozentig, ob wir das durchziehen, dieses Fest, wo wir ganz lange Stangen haben und dann alle schwarzen Menschen in der Stadt auf diesen Stangen, nee, das war, das kam von dir, oder nicht? Ja. Haben wir das gemacht, oder nicht? Pfingsten. Genau, Pfingsten, dass wir alle auf drei Meter lang sterben, alle Mooren der Stadt verbrennen, verbrennen, genau, nee, nee, anmalen, zunächst anmalen, dass wir sie weiss anmalen und wir dann suchen müssen, wer in der Stadt noch mohren versteckt. Lass uns das mal in der Hinterhand halten, vielleicht irgendwie was für nächstes Jahr. Für Pfingsten aber, oder? Für nächstes Jahr vielleicht. Aber ich finde, wir sollten noch mal bei Ostern sprechen, also allein so, allein vom Gefühl her ist es das noch nicht. Ich habe mir Folgendes vorgestellt, Wir brauchen ein Tier. Wir brauchen einmal ein Tier. Wir nehmen es Reh. Rehe legen keine Eier. Wir hatten schon die Eier. Ja, aber welche Tiere legen denn Eier? Schlangen oder was? Hasen? Hasen legen Hasenei? Habe ich mal gehört. Ja, okay, du kennst dich tatsächlich sehr gut mit Hasen aus. Du hast tatsächlich auch bei jedem einzelnen Festtag Hasen vorgeschlagen. Also lass uns die Hasen nehmen, lass uns die Eier nehmen. Und jetzt habe ich, ich denke ein bisschen out of the box, aber hörst dir kurz mal wenigstens an, okay? Ein grosses Feuer. Feuer? Osterfeuer, also ein grosses Feuer. Also sagen wir mal so, dass die, dass so freiwillige Feuerwehrs und sowas halt immer aufschütten und so, oder Bürgervereinigungen, halt so Vereine halt, die schütten das auf, so einen grossen, so einen Holzhaufen und die zündet man dann an. Und dann das Osterfeuer, Leute stehen da rum und gucken sich das an. Alle lieben Feuer. Zur gleichen Zeit Uhren, ne, die Idee mit der Uhr hatte ich dir erzählt. Mit den Uhren? Mit den Uhren. Dass wir da einfach sagen, wir stellen die an dem Tag einfach anders. Einfach umstellen. Oder ausmachen. Wir machen sie aus. Für eine Stunde. Und stellen sie dann eine Stunde nach hinten. Musst du dann nicht mehr. Ah, das ist ja geil. Clever. Wir stellen alle Uhren für eine Stunde aus. Ja. Aber das mit den Hasen hatten wir jetzt gebongt. Mit dem Feuer fandest du auch okay? Gebongt. Gebongt? Schreibt man das mit K oder mit G? Gebongt oder gebongt. Mit fünf K tatsächlich. Ähm, okay, wir brauchen auch noch Songs. Der coolste Ostersong? Hit me up before you go go Super Sweet Seventeen. Supertramp, alles von Supertramp. Machen wir mal zu Ostersongs. Ja. Supertramp, Easter Egg, Easter Egg. Und was macht man denn mit den Eiern? Also die Eier, die wirft man dann, also nimmt man dann und dann sucht man sich einen Schwarzen in der Stadt und wirft dann die Schwarzen auf die oder die ...
Nee, das war es anders, was war für Pfingsten. Eier versteckt man, würde ich sagen.
Damit die Schwarzen nicht finden.
Aber wenn man sie wiederfindet, malt man sie vorher an.
Sehr gut. Ah, sehr gut. Was sind denn die besten Oster-Stories? Top 5 Oster-Stories. Komm, wir hauen eine Rubrik raus.
Scheiss drauf.
Fuck it.
Boa, boa, boa, boa, boa, boa, boa, boa, boa, boa, boa, boa, dingelingelingelingelingelingelingelingeling. Ostern.
Ich hab mal ein Ei vergessen im Garten und es wurde dann zehn Jahre später gefunden und es stank.
Und seitdem gibt es tausendjährige Eier, die in Dschungelprüfungen benutzt werden.
Das war deine Idee. Tatsächlich, wir haben in unserer Familie erst früher immer bei unserer Oma und später dann bei uns zuhause immer Sachen versteckt. Und es ist immer mal sehr großer Spaß. Sachen versteckt? Ja, halt immer für jeden aus der Familie irgendwas gekauft, halt Schokoladen, Osterhasen oder so ein Kram und dann versteckt und teilweise auch die für die Brüder dann irgendwie in Bäumen ganz oben oder so, also wirklich krasse Verstecke. Ich hätte den Baum gekauft und den versteckt halt im Baum, im Wald. Im Bild des Waldes halt. Der hätte ihn nie gefunden, der würde heute noch suchen. Und da haben wir dann, da habe ich immer viel gesucht und ich weiß noch einmal, habe ich so Schokoeier für meinen Vater gekauft und habe die dann in seinem Auto versteckt, aber da war es relativ warm und sein Auto ist auch recht warm geworden. Deswegen habe ich irgendwann die Eier wieder aus dem Auto getan und in den Kühlschrank getan. Und dann bin ich mir zurückgegangen und habe BOW gezockt den Rest des Tages und am Abend kommt immer meine Mutter und sagt, sag mal, dein Vater sucht immer noch nach der Eier. Kannst du ihm ein bisschen helfen? Und ich so, oh shit, oh sorry. Nee, ich will das gar nicht. Er hätte einmal einen Kühlschrank suchen können. Aber es ist so gut die Vorstellung. Er sucht den ganzen Abend, die ganze Nacht durch nach etwas, was man nicht finden kann. Fand ich so schön. Flutin, mein Vater ist ja zehn Tage vermisst. Wo sucht er denn überall? Wo ist er, hat alles abgesucht. Ja, das ist schon gut. Angenommen, du, ich weiss, das ist eine schwierige Vorstellung, aber angenommen, wir werden mal irgendwann Väter. Ist echt schwer vorzustellen. Wie machen wir das? Also ich finde es aber auch schwierig, gerade bei Ostern den das, den Kindern das zu verklickern. Also gut, ich finde, man kann das akzeptieren, dass irgendwo ein Typ kommt, der alle Kinder, wenn sie brav waren, belohnt mit Geschenken. Aber ein Hase, der Eier gelegt hat, die man vorher angemalt hat, die man wahrscheinlich früher auch gekocht hat, dass das Kind gesehen hat. Doch, habe ich das habe ich glaube ich schon mal erzählt, ich habe meine Eltern mal erwischt, wie sie Eier gekocht haben. Okay, das geht in eine ganz andere Richtung. Wie sie Eier gekocht haben abends, vor Ostern halt. Und dann haben sie halt massiv viele Eier gekocht. Dann habe ich gesagt, was macht ihr da? Und dann hat mein Vater geistesgegenwärtig gesagt, ja fürgens ein Frühstück. Und dann habe ich gesagt, okay, alles klar. Und so Jahre später, gerade eben, ist mir eingefallen, das war Ostern wahrscheinlich, und wir haben einfach Eier für morgens vorbereitet. Ich finde es so gut, dass am nächsten Morgen sie Zähne knirschen, jedem Familienglied so einen Berg Eiern einfach auf dem Teller hatten. So, isst deine zwölf Eier, mein Sohn. Ja, das ist einfach zwölf Eier. Ja, weil sie in der Lüge bleiben mussten. Ja, klar, natürlich. Fände ich schlecht. Aber ich finde es auch gut, dass du als Kind siehst, wie deine Eltern Eier kochen und dann du das als Erwischen einordnest. Ist das jetzt so verrückt? Ich war ein sehr begeisterungsfähiges Kind. Ja, und ein sehr kontrollierendes, Kontrollfreak. Moment mal, hier kochen ein Ei mehr als wir Leute sind, erwischt! Ja, Stefan, wir haben einen Gast. Genau, und meine Eltern sich komplett beobachtet gefühlt haben und dann, da ist er wieder, sei ganz normal, bin ich nicht ganz normal. Erzählt schon wieder unsere Schuhe, das dritte Mal in dieser Woche, was ist mit diesem Kind draus? Das dritte Mal in dieser Stunde, was macht er da? Aber würdest du deinem Kind so die ganze Story erzählen? Kinder sind entweder sehr süss oder sehr gruselig, dazwischen gibt es nicht so viel. Kontrollieren alles die ganze Zeit. Ja, eigentlich schon. Würdest du deinem Kind die ganzen Mythologien erzählen, so grosser Hasen, oder würdest du dir was eigenes aussehen, oder würdest du sagen, schau dir die dummen Dreckskinder an vom Nachbarn, die in der Wiese rumlaufen, während du Playstation 8 zockst oder so? Ich glaube mein Problem wäre eher, dass Eltern zu mir kommen, andere Eltern von anderen Kindern und sagen, ihr Kind behauptet, es gäbe den Weihnachtsmann nicht und deshalb hat mein Kind den Glauben auch daran verloren. Dankeschön. Von solchen Kommentaren habe ich da Angst. Ich glaube nicht, dass Kinder auf andere Kinder hören. Klar, die hängen den ganzen Tag mit denen ab im Kindergarten. Warum weisst du so viel über Kinder? Was ist da los? Jürgen, sie gehen in den Kindergarten. Ich bin nicht mehr den ganzen Tag in der Spielecke oder in der Kuschel-Ecke oder in dem Monopoly-Spielen. Was war bei dir im Kindergarten der beliebteste Legostein? Gab es einen Legostein, um den sich alle immer gestritten haben? Kann man das vielleicht mal als Klingelton rausnehmen? Stefan will ich kein ,,Mmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmm war der beliebeste Legostein? Ich glaube, dieser grosse, der man unterdingen, als Anfang legt halt. Diese grosse Matte aus Stoppelnüne Quadratform. Die habe ich gar nicht benutzt tatsächlich. Ich habe nie was auf Platten gebaut. Ist stabiler. Ja, aber so Fahrzeuge oder so kannst du ja nicht auf. Das lernt man in der ersten Stunde Kindergarten, Lego-Kurs, montagsmorgens zwei Stunden Lego-Kurs, lernt man, dass es stabiler ist. Aber du kannst ja dann einen schlechten Raumschiff auf so einer Matte bauen. Was hattest du für Leistungskurse im Kindergarten? Ich hatte Lego und Sagerrand tatsächlich. Ich hatte andere Kinder schlagen und Essen klauen tatsächlich. Essen klauen? Bei uns war zumindest so ein zweimal zwei Block, weiß und er hatte noch einen roten Kreis an einer Stelle und Und der war so die Laserkanone. In unserer Vorstellung war das eine Laserkanone und die konnte man überall draufbauen. In deiner Vorstellung. Nee, ich habe mich da auch stark gestritten mit anderen Kindern. Um diesen Legostein. Ja, wenn du geschlafen hast im Kindergarten. Gay! Burned! Ja gut, okay. Okay. Ich habe mir immer von meiner Mutter, die mich in den Kindergarten gebracht hat, die Wörter Feuerwehr und Polizei aufschreiben lassen. Habe sie dann, während ich selber im Kindergarten war, die dann nachgeschrieben in meiner Schrift und den Leuten gezeigt, dass ich Feuerwehr und Polizei schreiben kann schon im Alter von einem Jahr oder so. Aber du wusstest nicht, was es bedeutet. Ich wusste nicht, was es bedeutet, aber ich habe Wörter geschrieben und ich war deswegen der King, der König des Kindergarten. Also der hätte auch Sieg Heil draufstehen können. Ja. Du hättest jedem… Das hat auch oft Mord und wer ist dieses Kind, adoptiert mich und so. Ja, töte mich, hilf mir. Genau, bring mich, weck mich einfach auf. Ja, aber das würde ich machen als Eltern. Ich würde sagen, Mama, wie schreibt man Polizist? Und ich würde halt irgendwie gnadenlos ein lustiges Wort haben. Satan oder so einfach aufschreiben. Dass ich mir ein bisschen dann noch ausdenken habe, was mir nicht einfällt. Ich habe doch jetzt ja nicht vorbereitet, was ich als Elternteil mache. Hallo? Das ist ja viel zu früh. Ich habe auch schon mal gesagt, dass ich dem Kind das Wort für Stuhl nicht beibringen würde oder für Danke. Das haben wir schon ein paar Mal erzählt. Ja, lass mich doch mal wiederholen wie Neueinsteiger. Es gibt keinen Neueinsteiger, wir haben Stefan Frier seit 18 Folgen, ansonsten kommt keiner. Wir kriegen keine Neuklicks. Der heißt Seiko Frier. Oh, Burn! Oder nicht? Was ist Burn? Nee, ich glaube, wir haben Leute dazugewonnen, die über Patreon gekommen sind, einfach weil sie gerne bezahlen. Die bezahlen lieber, als Folgen zu hören. Ja. Bezahlst du denn für andere Dienste, für andere Sachen im Internet? Ja, hauptsächlich für SOS-Kinderdörfer, UNICEF, SOS-Kinderdörfer, NPD. Und Satan ist noch da. Als Ausgleich, so 100 Euro an Pro-Asyl, 100 Euro an NPD. Und dann mal gucken, was passiert. Genau, zwei Armeen aufbauen. Eben, Also beide Armeen auffristen. Genau, die dann zusammen irgendwie zu beiden, irgendwie der Organisationsmanager werden und dann beide an einem Termin an einem Ort gegenüberstellen. Das ist eigentlich ganz geil. Und dann filmen. Wenn du ganz viel Geld hast, die Hälfte an die Linke, die Hälfte an die AfD und dann einfach zusehen, wie das Land zerreißt in der Mitte, wie einfach zwei enorm starke Kräfte in verschiedene Richtungen reissen und wie das Land in der Mitte auseinanderbricht.
Das fände ich mal lustig. Das fände ich mal eine gute Idee.
Ja, lustig oder menschenverachten, je nachdem. Es liegt auch bei einer beieinander.
Ja, Leute, spendet auf keinen Fall für die Lichte.
Wie hast du Ostern verbracht?
Ich habe hauptsächlich masturbiert und Dota gespielt und es war sehr besinnlich.
Und ich glaube, ich habe meine christlichen Pflichten erfüllt.
Ich war ja nochmal in München, zwischen der letzten Folge und heute, für ein anderes Podcast-Projekt. Mega cool. Und da bin ich mit dem Auto hingefahren. Und wir haben Rast gemacht bei so einem seltsamen Ort, wo es ein Haus gab, was auf dem Kopf war. Also einfach ein Haus auf dem Kopf. Das war so eine Attraktion da in diesem Stadtteil. Und dann habe ich dieses Haus mal angeguckt und dachte mir, cool, ein Haus auf dem Kopf, eigentlich ganz geil. So das Auto, da war auch ein Auto dann drin, was unter der, quasi auf der Garage stand, aber halt unten an der Decke hing dann quasi. Und dann stand ich davor und muss so erstaunt geguckt haben, dass die McDonald's-Mitarbeiterin, wo das war, war direkt mit McDonalds-Annehmen,
ist zu mir gegangen und hat gesagt, das haben die so gebaut, das haben die extra so gebaut, das Haus.
Und ich dachte mir auch so, ach echt, ich hätte mir jetzt echt Sorgen gemacht,
dass es irgendwie ein Wind ist, einfach auf den Kopf gedreht hat oder so.
Aber wie kann man gucken, wie erstaunt kann man gucken, dass die McDonalds-Mitarbeiterin zu mir kommen muss.
Ja, vor allem nicht nur erstaunt, sondern wie dumm auch muss man in der Situation gucken.
Ja, und jetzt ich verpflichtet gefühlt, mir zu sagen, nein, das haben die extra so gebaut.
Da hat ich mir auch so, ach echt, Dankeschön.
Das finde ich schon sehr schön.
Eine Kurzanecdote.
Ja.
Ist doch auch mal nicht schlecht.
Eine Kanekdote.
Stefan Tietze, nur weil du laufend Iso-Zeugs trinkst, wirst du kein Kollegah, du Lauch.
Danke. Wo genau kam das jetzt her? What? Hier schreibt einer, wieso drückt Pommes Ruppel den Lars-Erik Pausen immer weg, wenn er anruft? Und da fällt mir ein, dass heute sehr lange dein Handy neben mir lag, du weg warst und ich andauernd Lars-Erik Pausen weggedrückt habe. Aber dieses Rätsel auch gelöst, ja. Es hat genervt, dass andauernd neben mir das Handy vibriert hat. Ich habe es andauernd weggedrückt, ich habe andauernd Lars weggedrückt. Naja, als kleinen Sidestep. Es geht weiter. Bleibt dran, Leute, die Gags kommen gleich wieder. Mal kurz dran. schon überlege ich ein Buch zu schreiben. Ja. Und ich habe jetzt tatsächlich immer überlegt, das kapitelweise zu veröffentlichen, also kapitelweise zu schreiben, erstmal, vielleicht sollte ich erstmal darüber nachdenken. Das ist eine richtig gute Idee. Aber kapitelweise zu schreiben und immer so jeden Monat mal ein Kapitel davon online zu stellen, so quasi als Blog zu führen, aber nicht so richtig Blog. Und worum geht es denn im Buch? Das möchte ich noch nicht verraten, aber saugeil. Aber ist es eher ein Roman oder ist es eher so ein, ich sag mal. Es ist, glaube ich, eher Sitcom. Es ist, glaube glaube ich, eher so, jedes Kapitel kann auch für sich stehen, glaube ich. Es sollte eher so Sitcom-mäßig sein, lustig sein, Fiction. Aber ist es schon so die Verrücktheit der Welt gesehen durch die Brille eines Verrückten mit Zwanzigers und dessen Probleme so schon aus der Ecke, oder? Das ist ein erster Arbeitstitel, aber nein, eigentlich geht es um etwas ganz anderes. Spielen Tiere eine grosse Rolle? Ja, eine zu grosse Rolle. Du bist auch sehr selbstkritisch. Du beginnst das Buch auch mit. In meinen Zeugnissen damals in der Grundschule stand immer, Tiere spielen in seinem Leben eine zu grosse Rolle. Aber er ist auch sehr selbstkritisch. Also in Mathe, drei Bruss drei ist sechs, könnte auch fünf sein, ich bin mir nicht hundertprozentig sehr, vielleicht habe ich da einen Fehler gemacht. Wahrscheinlich habe ich einen Fehler gemacht, ich bin nicht so gut in diesem Fach, ich habe dann sehr viel, mein Lösungstext war immer sehr gross und falsch dann am Ende auch einfach. Fing richtig an. Einfach nochmal zu oft relativiert, so fünf durchgestrichen, sechs und es war immer die fünf, es war immer die erste Antwort, war richtig. Es ist immer die erste Antwort, aber Leute, das ist eine sehr gute Frage, ob die erste, die erste, was einem als erstes einfällt, ob das oft nicht die bessere Idee ist. Ich sage nein. Glaubst du, angenommen die Menschheit hätte, dass alle Leben, alle Menschen hätten immer nur den ersten Gedanken verfolgt. Glaubst du, die Menschheit wäre jetzt weiter? Nein. Genauso weit oder weniger weit? Weniger weit. Der Meinung bin ich auch. Du brauchst Leute, die einfach mal anfangen nachzudenken und ein bisschen tiefer ins Detail zu gehen. Es ist nicht immer nur alles schwarz-weiss. Genauso wenig kann man diese Frage beantworten. Ich finde, gerade bei Humor, gerade bei Comedy, finde ich, ist es sogar die, gehört es zur Kunst, nicht den erstbesten Gedanken zu nehmen. Sehr gut. Wenn jemand über Comedy kritisieren kann, dann der, der in den letzten halben Stunden Mörder die Sachen rauskommt. Wir beide. Also hört euch jetzt an, wie wir beide Comedy-Fünste euch von Humor erzählen. Ne, auf jeden Fall, also wenn du dann, keine Ahnung, zum Beispiel jemand in der Sendung heisst, der heisst Dieter Speck und dann ist das Erste, was dir einfällt, ist irgendwie weg mit dem Speck oder so ein Scheiss. Das ist das Erste, was dir einfällt und genau den darfst du nicht machen, weil den, den kann sich auch der Zuschauer ausdenken. Du als Profi musst aber den Anspruch haben, dass du mehr schaffst als das, was der Zuschauer schafft.
Weil weg mit dem Speck musst du gar nicht machen, weil das macht der Zuschauer schon. Es gibt jetzt ein neues Comedy-Special, was ich schon oft empfohlen habe, Tom Segura.
Endlich fällt mir ein Beispiel ein, wo ich den gut empfehlen kann.
Und zwar hat er gesagt, dass er sehr schlecht im Smalltalk ist und auch immer die erstbesten Dinge anspricht. Und hat er gesagt, wenn jemand von euch über 1,80 ist, es gibt keine Chance, dass ich es nicht erwähne. Ich werde sagen, spielst du wow, bist du gross, spielst du Basketball, wie ist die Luft da oben? Wenn du über 1,80 bist, ist es keine Chance, dass ich es nicht erwähne. Einfach so runtergerattert. Ja, super gut. Oh wow, toll. Das fand ich sehr lustig. Guck dich das an. Oder Florentins-Szenar-Special, was jetzt bald auf Netflix erscheint. Ja, tatsächlich. Meine Frau, der Krebs und ich haben jetzt tatsächlich veröffentlicht vor zwei Wochen. Und es kommt relativ schlecht an tatsächlich, weil ich ein Grossteil... Du hast nur einen Stern. Ich habe nur einen Stern tatsächlich bekommen. Aber auch nur, weil es null Sterne nicht gibt. Ja, ich habe mit Netflix gesprochen, habe gesagt, was ist da los. Und ich habe gesagt, tatsächlich, die Leute haben sich mehrfach bei uns gemeldet und gesagt, können wir nicht Null Sterne geben, aber es geht nicht, es geht tatsächlich nur ein Stern. Das Problem war vielleicht … Was war das Problem? Du bist wirklich der am einfachsten zu beeindruckenden Mensch. Du hast einen laufenden Motor. Ein Motor? Motor. Motor. Motor. Motor. Motor. Motor. Horror. Horror. Kor. Lass uns nochmal von vorne anfangen und überlegen, wie wir es hinkriegen, dass die Folge gut wird. Ich finde es ja auch immer die Frage, wollen Leute jedes Mal so eine aufgepeitschte Musical-Folge wie letzte Mal haben, wo wo wir wirklich komplett ausgerastet sind und sie klein davon Leib gerissen haben, kommentitechnisch? Oder halt auch mal so eine Folge wie heute, wo wir so ein bisschen in uns gehen und ein paar Hörspiele drin haben, ein paar ernste Sachen. Ich finde es nicht so schlecht, manchmal ein paar Sachen zu haben. Nee, ich glaube, die Leute wollen schon eher Energy, eher was gut ist. Du hast unsere Community. Nö. Wieso glaubst du, dass du weisst, was sie wollen?
Ich hasse nicht unsere Community, ich hasse nur die Community, die sich bemerkbar macht.
Den Rest mag ich.
Gibt es eigentlich Podcast-Pornos?
Ja, es gibt Hörpornos für Lastwagenfahrer, die dann auf der Strasse, wenn sie unterwegs sind, machen sie ein Porno an, so von wegen, rein, raus, rein, rein, raus, rein, wie viel geht es im Fenster? Ach, er holt nur seinen Cockring, alles klar. Jetzt legt sie sich hin, ich glaube, sie wird, nee, jetzt doch, im Hintergrund, die Pizza wird immer kälter. Die Pizza wird kälter, sie haben jetzt die Pizza, ich glaube, sie haben Salami bestellt, gross. Bestellt, aber gar nicht gegessen. Oder gar schon grosse Pizza für so eine kleine Frau.
Aber naja, was heisst kleine Frau, sie ist schon im Verhältnis, weil wenn sie sich
mal hinstellen. Jetzt wird das Erregel das Gliedhüter jetzt raus und führt es …
Das war schon Erregel bevor er in die Tür reingekommen ist.
Alles klar, okay, gut. Wer sind Sie jetzt? Entschuldigung, Sie reden mir an …
Ja, ich bin in diesem Raum, ich bin ein Tontechniker eigentlich.
Ja, ich wurde ja engagiert, diesen Tonporno zu machen. Alles klar, ich gehe einfach wieder raus. Ciao. Nee, nee, nee, nee. Ich sehe gerade, Sie sind ein bisschen Dekke angezogen hier in der Tonkabine, es ist immer recht warm. Ja, mir ist auch ein bisschen warm. Ich sehe einfach mal die Jacke aus, okay? Sie können die Jacke einfach ruhig an, wir können die ruhig hierhin hängen und die Heizung ist jetzt, tut mir leid, die Heizung habe ich jetzt ein bisschen warm. Ich habe sie schon ein paar Mal gesehen, aber sie haben ein bisschen abgenommen, kann das sein? Na ja, hier ... Kann ich mal kurz ... Oh, sie sind schönkörper. Ah, na ja, dankeschön. Sieht doch mal das Shirt aus, einfach mal so unverbindlich. Wie bitte? Was? Sie meinen, weil es tontechnisch ein bisschen ... Hie singen? Weil man es ein bisschen hört auf dem Mikrofon oder wie. Es knistert ein bisschen. Ja, dann wenn sie das sagen, dann ziehe ich doch mal ... Sie Sieh doch mal aus kurz. Sie haben einen sehr schönen Körper tatsächlich. Danke schön. Was war das für den Sport? Ein bisschen Squash spielig. Squash? Squash. Ich liebe Squash. Wirklich? Ja. Wir können ja mal zusammen Squash spielen. Wie sagen wir Squasher immer? Auf zum Squash! Ja, das stimmt. Das sagen wir. Wir haben ja so viel gemeinsam. Das ist ja interessant. Ja. Tschau! Jetzt sehen wir wieder an. Gut, dann haben wir alles. Ich glaube, wir verlassen jetzt die Realität dieses Hörspiels, weil ich glaube, die werden so nicht mehr produziert tatsächlich. Könnte aber sein, da bin ich mir jetzt nicht hundertprozentig sicher, wir können in der Richtung noch bleiben. Oder die Maulwürfe! Woo, Maulwürfe! Aus Bonn! Nee, der ist aber sehr lustig. Lass uns doch mal über die letzte Folge reden. Einfach genau. Lustig meine letzte Folge.
Best of. Wir wollten immer schon mal ein Best of machen, aber es klappt nie. Aber ist auch nicht unsere Aufgabe eigentlich, oder? Eigentlich schon. Das ist ziemlich genau unsere Aufgabe als Podcaster und Produzent. Ich finde, man sollte mal jemanden beauftragen, irgendwie einen Tonmann oder irgendwie unser Tonpraktikant, Timo. Ne, wir wenden uns an so eine Agentur. Na ganz kurz, also wir spielen ja mit offenen Karten. Wir verdienen ja das Geld mit diesem Podcast. Patreon ist aktiv, ihr könnt uns Geld geben. Und wir sind aber ein Podcast, der zurückgibt. Wir wollen auch einen Teil dieses Geldes wieder in den Podcast fliessen lassen. Wir wollen nicht nur alles nehmen und selbst für uns benutzen. Und so haben wir uns entschieden. Ich glaube, die Seite ist dafür, dass man nur alles ins Projekt wieder einfließen lässt. Ja, aber wir denken einen Schritt weiter. Wie können wir die Hälfte von dem, was zurückkommt in dieses Projekt? Wie können wir zehn Prozent von dem, was kommt? Genau, was machen wir mit den drei Prozent der Einnahmen, die wir in dieses Projekt stecken wollen? Und da wäre dann mal eine interessante Möglichkeit, dass wir vielleicht uns jemanden besorgen, der Best ausschneidet. Ich wäre auch für ein Redesign unseres Logos, zum Beispiel Magenta. Halt einfach, dass es so ein bisschen mal anders, ein anderer Wind reinkommt. Ich würde aber gerne nicht so viel bezahlen. Was glaubst du, kostet jemand, der hier einfach für eine Podcastaufnahme jongliert? Die ganze Zeit? Der einfach eine Stunde lang jongliert, den wir uns in die Tonkabine holen. Ja gut, aber wie viel und womit? Ich kann selber mit drei Bällen jonglieren. Mit Maiskolben. Wie lang? So ein Bio-Jongleur vielleicht, der einfach hier mit so drei Maiskolben reinkommt und jongliert und einfach die gesamte Aufnahme und wir ihn aber nicht beachten, sondern einfach nur aufnehmen. Das fände ich super. Oder so ein Gebärdensprachendolmetscher, den wir dann abfilmen, der die gesamte, aber auch beide reden, der die gesamte Folge in Gebärdensprache macht und wir veröffentlichen erst die Gebärdensprache und dann müssen die Leute raten, worüber wir gesprochen haben. Er hat während des Jobs zwölf Kilo abgenommen. Genau, aber ich habe keinen Bock mehr auf die... Boah, stell dir vor, jemand muss uns beide gleichzeitig dann die ganze Zeit irgendwie nachminken. Das ist, glaube ich, echt hart. Aber ich habe überhaupt keinen Bock mehr, Gebärdensprache zu machen. Ich lasse es einfach. Ich mache jetzt einfach nur... Ich würde auch die ganze Zeit solche Wörter sagen wie... Blowjob, Blowjob, Blowjob. Das ist eins zu eins ein Nick-Thune-Gag. Oder einfach die ganze Zeit sowas wie Mammutbaum oder so Dinge, die er hundertprozentig nicht wissen kann. Ja, genau. Und dann immer so gucken, was er jetzt macht. Mammut, fängt er dann an, zu buchstabieren oder was? Keine Ahnung, also wirklich so ganz spezielle Worte, irgendwie so Quantenphysik oder heisenbergsche Unschärfe-Relation oder sowas in der Richtung. Einfach gucken, was die daraus machen und immer so schwitzen und so. Sinuskurve. Ja, du weißt ja, Unschärfe, du weißt, was ich meine. Viel von Gebärdensprache ist auch dieses, komm, du weißt Komm schon, dieses erforderte, dieses ... Na, wie heisst du mal? Mit Schnipsen.
Genau, dieses ... Komm, du weisst doch, was ich meine. Komm schon, dieses Erfordernde, dieses ... Komm, dieses ... Na, wie heisst du noch mal? Wie ein Schnipsen. Genau, dieses ... Komm, hier, wie heisst du noch mal, hier, zwei und halb Stunden lang, Gesamtvortrag. Hast du mir erklärt, dass Gehörlose ... kurz beim Behinderten-Gang es kurz, damit wir wieder dieses einfache Vorgang gewinnen, dass Behinderte, ähm, Behinderte Schwergehörige, die halt die Gebärdensprache brauchen. Hörige, Schwörige. Gehörige, dass die klatschen, indem sie ihre Hände hochnehmen und sehr doll ihre Handinnenflächen nach aussen wedeln. Also so Jazzhands-mäßig. So Jazzhands-mäßig quasi. Und man kann ja auch klatschen so, ja, es hat mir gefallen, ich stimme zu, aber du kannst nicht diese Jazz-Sense machen, ohne dabei unfassbar euphorisches Gesicht zu machen. Du musst immer so breit grinsen und so. Ja, ja, aber es gibt auch Situationen, wenn man klatscht in, keine Ahnung, irgendwie zum Beispiel jemand ist gestorben, man macht so einen Rückblick und danach klatschen alle höflich. Genau, und es geht bei den Tauben recht schlecht, weil es immer so... Nein, du kannst nur euphorisch klatschen, so zugabemässig, aber du kannst nicht so klatschen, in dem Sinne dass du sagst, hör, hat mir jetzt gefallen. Ich glaube, da gibt es auch schon Abschwächungen. Wenn du so niedrig, dann ist es so wahr, okay. Aber wenn du ganz hoch wedelst, dann ist es, glaube ich, stärker tatsächlich. Das sollten wir echt mal machen. Wir holen uns so einen Gebärdensprachenguy und lassen den alles übersetzen, synchron, Livestream. Finde ich echt gut. Live-Folge hatten wir auch mal überlegt, eine 24-Stunden-Live-Folge machen wir für 10.000 Euro. Weil wir so viel zu sagen haben, für 100.000. Nee, nichts zu sagen haben. Also, ich würde einfach deine Webcam quasi in deinem Schlafzimmer installieren. Ein guter Freund von mir, äh, Big Brother-laub ich dir schon nicht. Du musst authentisch bleiben. Mein Bruder, Lars Pausen, der streamt manchmal auf YouNow. Das ist so eine Streaming-Plattform, wo Leute streamen und dann kann man als Zuschauer denen Geld geben, Geld spenden. Und da hat er einmal bei einem Stream wahnsinnig viel Geld verdient, also irgendwie 100 Euro oder sowas auf einmal. Und er hatte geguckt und es kam alles von einer Person. Und er stand in Kontakt mit so einer Kontaktperson von YouNow, weil die so ein Projekt geplant haben. Und dann hat er mich gefragt, so, ja, was ist denn da los? Und er so, ja, das ist ganz normal, das sind meistens so Scheiche aus Saudi-Arabien und die schauen sich ganz gerne blonde Menschen an. Er versteht kein Wort von dem, was er sagt, aber die schauen sich einfach gerne blonde Menschen an und schenken ihr einfach Geld, weil sie blond sind. Und es scheint tatsächlich ein Geschäftsmodell auf YouNow zu sein, dass einfach blonde Menschen streamen den ganzen Tag und einfach einen grossen Teil ihrer Einnahmen von Scheichs bekommen, die einfach nur Geld geben, weil sie blond sind, ohne dass sie einen Einwurf verstehen von dem, was sie sagen. Das ist schon eigentlich ganz geil. Aber auch geil, dass der Scheich so weit geht, dass er nicht nur blonde Menschen sehen will, sondern blonde Menschen auch bezahlen will, dafür, dass sie blond sind. Ja, vor allem, ich fände es auch so geil, dass diese YouNow-Mitarbeiterin das so erzählt hat, als wäre das so... Also natürlich so, unser Geschäftsmodell beruht darauf, dass Leute aus komplett bescheuerten Gründen anderen Leuten Geld geben. Für Blonde, genau. Das finde ich grossartig. Auch noch rassistisch auf irgendeine Art. Wollen wir uns nicht blonde Perücken, so Langhaarperücken aufsetzen und dann bei
Juden auch eine Folge machen?
Das wäre für nicht geil.
Ich glaube, unsere Leute würden das gar nicht so schlecht finden, auch um uns blond zu
sehen.
Ich habe ähnlichen Gründen, meine Haare blond zu sehen.
Aber wir müssen uns eigentlich die Haare blond färben, wir können nicht blonde Perücken
haben.
Ich hatte mal eine Zeit lang blonde Strähnchen, als ich noch sehr klein war.
Als ich noch sehr klein war, ja.
Ja. Aber hattest du auch mal so einen Obi-Wan-Kenobi-Zopf, so einen kleinen Zopf so hinten dran? Der, glaube ich, hätte genau zu dir gepasst. In einer gewissen Zeit hätte er gut zu dir gepasst. Ich hatte sehr lange, sehr helle blonde Haare. Es ist irgendwann gekippt, ich weiß auch nicht, weil ich damals in den Frug voll Pech gefallen bin oder keine Ahnung. Dein Krug. Da ist er wieder. Gehirn, lass mich jetzt nicht im Schiff. Der ungute Stefan ist wieder da. Ich hätte so einen Topfschnitt ganz lange in meinem Leben, so einen Topfschnitt. Ich kann es nicht deutlicher formulieren, einen Topfschnitt. Ja, ja, ich verstehe auch, was gemeint ist. Weil du keine Reaktion zeigst, meine Augen sind tot. Welche Reaktion soll ich auf den Topfschnitt zeigen? Ich weiss nicht, jubeln kurz oder so, wenn die Händen wedeln. Aber wir müssen uns mal, genau, für die ersten 100 Euro, die wir einnehmen, färben wir uns für einen Tag die Haare blond und machen einen Stream auf YouNow. Wir haben jetzt schon fast 100 Euro eingenommen, das ist nicht gut. Auf YouNow, einfach um noch mehr Geld von arabischen Scheiss zu bekommen. Finde ich eigentlich ganz gut. Wir lassen uns während des Streams die Haare blond färben. Von einer Gebärdendolmetscherin die Haare blond färben, die aber selber grüne Haare hat.
Blond ist relativ normal und relativ verbreitet.
Wie viele sind bereit, Leute zu zahlen für zum Beispiel grüne Haare oder pinke Haare oder blaue Haare oder rote Haare oder braune Haare oder schwarze Haare oder frauen Haare oder schwarze Haare oder frauen Haare oder schwarze Haare oder fragezeichen Haare oder ultramarinenblaue Haare oder kaki Haare oder schwarze Haare oder frau- frauenha- oder schwarze Haare oder
pinke Haare oder ultramarinenblaue Haare oder Kaki-Haare, Kaktus, Tetris, Flasche.
Tetris, Blöcke die runterfallen, Türme aus rotem Gold, Das war kein Witz! Was hältst du von folgendem Star Wars-Sketch? Dass die ein Konzert spielen, aber alle sauer sind, dass sie nur einen Song haben. Du meinst so wie bei Family Guy? Ja, eins zu eins wie bei Family Guy. Aber das war, also um nochmal an die besten Gags zurückzudenken, das war einer der besten Gags aller Zeiten. Die Vorstellung, Episode 4, also die Story, Junge in der Wüste, trifft so einen alten, mysteriösen Mann, er zeigt ihm diese Zauberkraft, er zeigt ihm das Lichtschwert, er will in die Welt nachher ausziehen, um phantastische galaktische Abenteuer zu sehen. Sie gehen in diese Bar, wo diese Band im Hintergrund spielt und ab dann verfolgt die Handlung und die Kamera nur noch diese Band, wie sie ihre eigenen bei einem Agenten sitzt und einen neuen Deal aushandelt und irgendwie ein Albumcover schiessen muss. Der eine hat wahnsinnige Drogenprobleme, der eine hat wahnsinnige Minderbändigkeitsprobleme, sie steht auf die Freundin vom Keyboarder. Der neue Song kommt nicht an, aber er will seine kreativen Visionen durchsetzen. Und die macht, wenn man so eine Rolle spielt, wenn man so eine Untergeordnete, dass bei einem Auftritt so ein besoffener Jedi mal irgendwie das Keyboard zerstört hat, aber so eine ganz uncoole Rolle spielt, aber noch da ist. Oder einmal in so einem Raumschiff sieht man im Hintergrund, wie Luke im Raumschiff so vorbeifliegt oder so. Im Hintergrund wird sie die Story erzählt, man sieht so, das ist die eigentlich bessere Story, aber ich schaue mir jetzt diese Story hier an. Das ist auch so, ich habe neulich so ein, ich habe irgendwie aus Spaß, habe ich mir so ein Playstation-Spiel gekauft, wo man gegen andere kämpft und als Batman Joker, das heißt Injustice, so ein klassisches Beat'em-up-Spiel. Und dann kann man in so einer Arena kämpfen, wo im Hintergrund so zwei Riesenwesen gegeneinander kämpfen. Und man kämpft dann vorne die ganze Zeit mit Batman, dem Joker und Superman und so, denken sich aber da hinten ist der viel geilere Kampf. Leute, ich würde lieber den da hinten spielen. Ich würde lieber den da hinten sehen, einfach nur. Das wäre einfach cool. Du steuerst nur noch links, damit du die Szenerie da hinten sehen kannst. Ja. Was? Ich glaube, Jan Böhmermann ist gerade im Raum neben uns. Echt? Oder ist es nur Tom? Nee, das ist Tom. Ach Mann, ey! Hunde-Gum, Hunde-Gum! Wenn sich das transportiert, war das sehr lustig.
Ist schon blöd, wenn ein Typ, der einfach random hier reinkommt, lustiger ist als wir in 40 Minuten.
Stefan und Florentin werden zu einer Person, sie verschmelzen einfach zu einem Menschen. Ich glaube, in Folge 1000 können wir nicht mehr unterscheiden, wer wer ist.
Wir reden genau gleich und wir fangen an, genau dasselbe zu sagen, nur gleichzeitig quasi, wie so ein Echo, was halt zu früh kommt.
Wie wär's, wenn wir mal eine Folge komplett synchron sprechen würden, also jeden Satz einfach gleichzeitig sagen und jeder Gag von Fiedlein bis zum Ende, die man auch in einem gewissen professionellen Umfeld als professionelle Comedy-Autoren manchmal Du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du ...Dudududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududud spannend. Das ist sehr, sehr interessant. Hallo, mein Name ist Stefan, ich bin Steven, und ich liebe Mammutbäume. And I love mammoth trees. Wow, Podcast Entertainment von Feinsten. Nee, ich find's geil, wenn wir wetten, das oder so, irgendwann der Synchronsprecher so überschwenkt in, jetzt muss ich mal kurz nachgucken, was das Wort heisst. Und dann eben so zehn Minuten lang, die reden schon gar nicht mehr Englisch, ist schon die nächste Wette am Laufen, aber er die ganze Zeit noch am Mikro, ganz nah am Mikro. Oder wenn sich die Dynamik ändert und er irgendwann... Das habe ich schon mal, irgendwann auch Leute anruft, so Native Speaker anruft und fragt, was das heisst. So ein Problem Mammutbaum, was soll das heissen? Oder irgendwann diese Dynamik ändert und er Dinge schon sagt bevor. Der andere sagt immer so ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne neene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, was man vorsagt.
Mein Name ist Stefan Michael Dietze. Ich liebe isotonische Getränke und ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich noch viel zu wenig davon trinke. Man sollte sehr viel davon trinken. Ich bin 21 Jahre alt, ich hasse Menschen.
Ich hasse andere Menschen im speziellen Florenti. Und ich versuche gerade herauszufinden, wie schnell man sprechen muss, damit der Synchron-Sprache einen komplett verliert. Ich habe Synchron-Sprache gesagt, aber ich meinte eigentlich simultaner Setser. Ich glaube, dass er komplett erzieht aus der Kastil-Altrache, der andere Sprache ist, dass er Spanisch schneller als Englisch. Er benutzt es als Showreel und benutzt auch andere Sprachen, um zu zeigen, dass er gut ist. Du bist das gar nicht mehr, okay, alles klar, ciao. Ja, dann mach du mal. Ich... Sprich du mal Englisch. Und du sprichst auf Deutsch? Ja. Nee, damit du dich jetzt genauso blamieren kannst, sprich ich auf Deutsch und du übersetzt. Das ist nicht blamiert, du hast das ganz gut gemacht. Ich bin Stefan. I'm Steven. Und ich liebe Gurken. I love Cucumbers. Was like are these lamps that are stuck under the roof, under the ceiling. You know, these round, these very light, big things under the ceiling, you know what I mean, okay?
He's not talking anymore, I don't know. He's dead, I think he's dead. Oh my god, there's a lot of blood, oh my god! Somebody check, could somebody call 911? Now please, oh my god! Sehr gut, du wusstest, was Grundleuchter heisst, so gut. Was heißt Grundleuchter? Chandelier. Ich wusste das dann Stefan nicht. Und … Was heißt Barsch? Bicker. Lachs? Salmon? Lachsbarsch? Salmonbicker? Barschfrucht. Bickerfruit so many Gags rausgehauen, diese Folge, deswegen würde ich dich jetzt bitten. Also ein paar Gags. Feedline, Punchline, ganz klassisch, ich sag die Feedline und dann überleben wir uns zusammen eine Punchline. Dann sag ich eine Feedline und du sagst eine Punchline. Genau. Was ist der Unterschied zwischen einem Vorhang und einer Vorhaut?
Das, was aus dem Vorhang kommt, will man öfter sehen, äh, lieber sehen.
Was?
Das, was aus dem Vorhang kommt, äh... Aus dem Vorhang kommt!
Was aus dem Vorhang kommt!
Ich möchte nochmal lösen, ich möchte lösen.
Das, was aus dem Vorhang kommt, sieht man lieber an, wenn man hört dem lieber zu.
Der Vorhang ist allgemein lustig.
Ja, was ist der Unterschied, wie viele Feiertage braucht man, um sich zu erholen? Drei. Das sieht aus dieser Antwort. Warum sind die Nilpferde zum Flughafen gegangen? Weil sie in Köln waren und Rheinpferde sich nicht so gut anhörte. Sind dann in Ägypten geflogen dann? Ich hör mal ganz kurz, ob jemand lacht. Nein. Schade. Ey, wir machen das jetzt jede Folge, bis wir das richtig gut können. Mit dem gleichen Feedline. Ja, aber machen wir eine vernünftige Pause. Weshalb ist dein Mikrofon übersteuert? Wie angestrengt du gerade nachdenkst, als wäre es wirklich wichtig, darüber sich Gedanken zu machen. Also ihr dachtet, das wäre die Feedline? Ja. Warum ist mein Mikrofon gerade übersteuert? Wissen die Leute, dass eine Socke auf meinem Mikrofon ist? Die nachfolgenden Sendungen verschieben sich um 20 Minuten. Was kann man nicht? Halt, stopp! Verschiebe dich nicht, das ist ein Podcast, wir können pausieren. Ihr könnt jetzt aufhören. Lass uns doch mal anfangen, ganz kurz. Mein Name ist Stefan, das Sonnenschef für Spaß und ich glaube, wir geben jetzt Gas, wir haben die Gags, wir haben den Fun und ich glaube, wir rappen jetzt zusammen. Für ein Team ist sie gegenüber, von mir er rappt, er rappt, er rappt, er rappt, er rappt. Meine Rhyme sind so hart wie ein Diamant, ihr habt mich jetzt bald schon wieder erkannt, weil ihr mich schon kennt, ihr habt schon mal meine Podcast gehört, weil das ist Folge 45. Und es hat euch bislang nie gestört. Sie ist unerhört. Stefan ist auch im Raum. Für mich ist er ein Traum. Ich glaube es kaum, aber... Rom ist für mich nur Schaum und Rauch und Schaum. Du hattest den Raum, du hattest den Reim schon, aber hast dann noch ein Wort draufgelegt, weil schon ein Sänger besser passt. So läuft das nicht. Aber hat mal jemand gecheckt, was in den Köpfen von Freestylern vorgeht? Die müssen doch sehr gut drauf sein, die Jungs. Mensch, was ist da los? Wir haben es doch richtig drauf. Sie können nicht ihre gesamte Doktorarbeit in dieser Stimme halten. Hat sich jemand da gefragt, was zwei Protonen im Luftlärmeren Raum macht? Ich habe Leute gefragt, was die mir gesagt haben. Ihr glaubt das, ne? Man kann alles in dieser hohen Stimme sagen und es ist automatisch cool. Nein, nicht cool, aber irgendwie, man bleibt doch doch dran, was hat er uns zu sagen? Hat so einen energetischen Unterton. Warum ist er in dieser Stimme? Was will er uns noch erzählen? Und wie schaffen Sie es da wieder rauszukommen? Was weiss er alles noch, wenn er das schon weiss? Ich will mehr von ihm hören. Man kommt ja gleich wieder raus. Oder nicht, ich weiss es nicht. Jetzt bin ich doch wieder drin. Ähm, es mal, Bits von anderen Comedien als unsere eigenen ausgeben. Hey, hey, hey, nicht mit Mikrofon gegen Kopf. Mein Name ist Stefan, das Fund steht für Spaß und mir gegenüber sitzt Florentin, die Comedy Queen. R-Queen. Du lässt dich zu sehr ablenken. Stefan, Stefan, Stefan, hey, psst! Ist ein Problem, wenn man während der Podcastaufnahme, wenn man am Fenster sitzt und dann fährt er einfach am Auto vorbei. Hattest du schon mal bei einem Buch einen Moment, wo du einen Satz gelesen hast und das Buch kurz zugemacht hast und aus dem Fenster geschaut hast? Und dann nachgedacht hast über den Satz? Ja. Oder einfach nur, weil du den Vogel in dem Garten noch nie gesehen hast und überlegt hast, wow, was ist das für ein Vogel? Und hey, ich habe auch noch Hausaufgaben zu tun und oh mein Gott, ich sollte vielleicht etwas essen, vielleicht ist es im Kühlschrank noch ein bisschen Kinderbuenen.. Wem gehört dieses Haus, warum bin ich in diesem Haus? Kinder-Buenus hältst du im Kühlschrank?
Das war jetzt im Freestyle. Comedy ist auch ein bisschen besser wie Freestyle, da habe ich jetzt ein Wort gesagt, was nicht so ganz reinpasste.
Aber ja, tatsächlich halt ist es im Kühlschrank. Genau wie Choco-Fresh. Choco-Fresh.
Choco-Fresh gibt es ja gar nicht mehr. Doch, Choco-Fresh gibt es aber Happy-Hippo-Snack gibt es nicht mehr.
Aber es ist das Wort. Happy-Hippo-Snack ist jetzt Choco-Fresh. Habe, aber Happy Hipposnack gibt's nicht mehr. Aber es ist das Wort. Happy Hipposnack ist jetzt Schoko-Fresh.
Habe ich nicht verstanden, diese Revolution.
Ja.
Ciao.